remember in high school yearbooks all of
those superlatives most likely to
succeed or most likely to do
who knows what end up in prison I don't
remember what they were in my high
school there's sort of analogies within
the trump cabinet right the most corrupt
the most morally reprehensible the most
self aggrandizing whatever for most
incompetent I still go back to Betsy
DeVos who was just completely and
totally out of her league during her
confirmation hearings really an
embarrassment to the country someone who
has no business whatsoever being
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos
recently went to parkland Florida the
site of the recent mass school shooting
that left 17 dead as most of you know
lied about what she did there at least
exaggerated and then walked out of her
own press conference when the question
started to get a little bit tough the
the completely abortive visit to
parkland Florida started with a visit to
the school itself a Marjorie
Stoneham Douglass High School student
journalists immediately started tweeting
that Betsy DeVos was not answering their
questions they wanted to talk to her it
was a school visit and she's the
Secretary of Education makes sense that
they would talk to her and here's where
it starts to sort of get a little weird
DeVos said to reporters adult reporters
that she toured the school with the
student journalists it appears that
that's sort of like the most charitable
charitable possible interpretation of
how it went she reportedly was seen by a
couple of students who took pictures of
her but by all accounts saying that she
toured the school with the student
journalist is an exaggeration she then
decided to hold a press conference now
to understand this next part recall her
totally nugatory confirmation hearings I
like that word she said she'd be up for
arming teachers in case they maybe need
to protect the students from a grizzly
bear attack instant classic right
instinct viral video so at the press
conference students understandably
wanted to ask her about arming teachers
totally obvious totally expected you've
got the Secretary of Education in a
school after a mass shooting when both
she and the president that she works for
serves that the pleasure of have said we
want to look at arming teachers they
are going to be questions about arming
teachers she didn't like it she ended up
just walking away from her podium
effectively ending her own press
conference we've got a little bit of
video the audio from it is not not the
best but let's take a look Thank You
secretary Thank You secretary I love
that totally trigger which of trumps
people aren't clowns like can somebody
give me the list and I want to go back
to what I said at the start of the
segment can anyone email me or tweet me
if you can think of another Trump
administration official that is less
qualified to perform their job in the
administration than Betsy DeVos please
get in touch with me and if they could
find someone to even somewhat appear
competent in some of these positions
it's almost like they don't care and I
actually think that's the saddest part
of it that I don't think they do care
they just want to appoint there France
I'd like to nominate ben Carson
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development
to do what I also Rick Perry Oh
Secretary of Energy most incompetent
well Rick Perry is at least from a state
that I don't know has both oil and a big
sort of like solar and and wind say I'm
really struggling here yeah I know that
they're not particularly competent but I
I still even think that Betsy DeVos is
less qualified for the position than ben
Carson merely because I think Ben Carson
is generally more intelligent and could
sort of at least learn by doing in a way
that Betsy DeVos seems totally unable to
do but hey you know what I'm willing to
have my mind changed who is less
qualified and less competent than Betsy
DeVos and Trump's cabinet today's
program is made possible in part by
blinken
most people understandably right just
don't have all the time in the world to
do all the reading that they want to do
I certainly don't have the time I would
like to have to do the reading I'd like
to be
and maybe you're reading a good book now
as I am but you've still got 10 other
books on your reading list and you just
don't know how you're ever gonna get to
them all this is why the app called
blink is exists and is so great
they've taken thousands of the world's
best non-fiction books on a wide variety
of topics and they've boiled them down
to the most important information from
each book and they make it available to
you in these packages that you can read
in 15 minutes or listen to in 15 minutes
in audio form you can sit down and in 15
minutes
absorb the most important insights from
these non-fiction books that you've
probably been trying to find time to
read or you can listen to the audio in
the car or at the gym or wherever you
are popular and critically acclaimed
books are available on politics
economics science I saw some great books
on entrepreneurship and investing and
it's free to try but you can get a 20%
discount on a yearly membership if you
go to blink is comm slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube we're linking
there in the description below the video
and if you want to type it into your web
browser it is blink accom /pa que ma n I
encourage you to check it out